المشرف العام على مركز الملك سلمان للغايه
الدكتور عبدالله ربيع دكتور عبد الله حياك
الله معي في نشره الرابعه نريد فقط ان
نشير الى ان هذه الحمله حمله جمع التبرعات
للحمل الشعبيه السودانيه لغاته الشعب
السوداني انطلقت تقريبا قبل ساعتين وثلث
وبلغ مجموعها اكثر من حتى الان يعني وصلت
الى اكثر من 340 بانتظار التحديثات في هذه
الارقام دكتور
اولا تقييمكم الاولي لحجم الاثر الانساني
جراء هذه الحرب التي تعيشها السودان اليوم
مرحبا خالد ومرحبا بمشاهده العربيه بلا شك
ان السوداني يعاني من تحديات كبيره قبل
بدء هذه الاحداث بوضع انساني ليس جيد
وجاءت هذه الاحداث التي تضاعف الاحتياج
الانساني حسب التقديرات الاوليه هنالك
اكثر من 15 مليون
سوداني بحاجه الى دعم انساني سواء كان في
مجال التغذيه او الصحه او الايواء اكثر من
300 الف نجحوا بسبب هذه الاحداث التي حصلت
في السودان
وكذلك الاوضاع الصحيه كانت هشه قبل
الاحداث وازدادت الحسابي بسبب هذه
اذا جاءت توجيهات خالد محرمين الشريف
بدعم سخي من الدوله حفظها الله بمئه مليون
دولار وكذلك كما اشرت اخي خالد باطلاق
حمله تبرعات شعبيه لغاته الشعب السوداني
الشقيق عبر منصه ساهم والتي من خلال قناه
العربيه ندعو رجال الاعمال والمحسنين
والمتبرعين بالمساهم الفاعله
لتخفيف معاناه الشعب السوداني الشقيق ما
هي الخطه المعتمده من قبل المركز
لنقل هذه المساعدات الى ايصالها كيف سيتم
توزيعها ايضا بعد دخولها الى السودان
معك
الان
خطه هو الى السودان وكذلك نقل مواد اخرى
عبر البحر من خلال جسر بحري كذلك تم
التواصل سواء مع المنظمات الدوليه او
المنظمات المحليه للعمل في السودان ونقلها
الى اكثر احتياجا المناطق الاكثر احتياجا
وهي كما اشرتم في قناه العربيه هي مناطق
الجزيره هو كارديفان ودار وسنار
وكذلك سوف يكون هنالك
عاملين على الارض من منسوب مركز الملك
سلمان للنغاثه وعمال الانسانيه
للمساهمه في وصول هذه المساعدات ونامل
باذن الله عند استقرار الوضع سوف كذلك
تشارك الفرق التطوعيه سواء الصحيه او
غيرها
لاجراءات صحيه لتخفيف المعاناه الصحيه لدى
المحتاجين الجسر الجوي متى سينطلق
يعتمد على حصول التصاريح اللازمه نحن
جاهزون لكن نعمل على حصول التصاريح
الجاهزه ان يكون هناك تنسيق بين طرفي
الصراع او ماذا دكتور
انا اعتقد انه تنسيق مع المنظمات المحليه
وضمان وصول هذه المساعدات دون اي تدخل
خارجي من اطراف النزال هل يجري الاتصال
والتنسيق مع طرفي النزاع يعني اللي هم من
يتصارع اليوم على الارض يعني في مناطق
متعدده من السودان دكتور
تاكيد من خلاله وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
هنالك
اول ضمان مامونيه
الوصول الانساني وتامين سواء كان النقل
الجوي او البحري او كذلك البري داخل
السودان من المهم يا اخي خالد ان ليس فقط
ان تصل الى الميناء او الى المطار الاهم
هو وصولها عبر الحافلات البريه الى ذوي
الاحتياج الاعلى لذلك هنالك تواصل على
مستوى عالي من وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
لضمان مامونيه وصول هذه المساعدات بالشكل
الاسرع والامن الاولويه للولايات الاكثر
تاثرا اللي ذكرتها
البحر الاحمر شمال دارفور هذا حتى حسب
تقديرات الامم المتحده الاخيره ليس كذلك
دكتور جيد
وكذلك تقديرات مركز الملك سلمان كما تعلم
لدينا
منظمات محليه نتعامل معها وتواصل مستمر
ونتفق مع ما ذكرتهم منظمات الامم المتحده
ان هذه المنا الاكثر احتياجا في السودان
في هذه الايام خاصه هناك يعني مشاكل تتعلق
بمناطق مراكز الرعايه الصحيه يعني وغيرها
ايضا هل هي مشموله
الخرطوم العاصمه
صحيح الخرطوم العاصمه والناجحون لجنوب
العاصمه الخرطوم هنالك خطه لدعم القطاع
الصحي
بما يضمن تامين العلاج اللازم لذوي
الاحتياج
من سيتولى التامين الافراد افراد المركز
دكتور
العاملين على الارض
نعمل مع اولا المنظمات الامميه والمنظمات
المحليه وكذلك كما اشرت هنالك تواصل على
مستوى العالم مامونيه العاملين من منسوب
المركز
وسوف نتاكد ان منسوب المركز يذهبون
للمناطق الاكثر امانا في الجنوب التي نزح
عليها
النازحون من الخرطوم والمناطق المجاوره
لها الخطه ستكون على شكل مراحل المرحله
الاولى يعني حسب المعلومات الاوليه ستكون
على شكل مراحل المرحله الاولى ستركز على
الادويه على الغذاء
الحجم الذي يحتاجه الان وبالتالي ماذا عن
المراحل الاخرى التاليه
طبعا
[موسيقى]
النازحين ويتبعها كذلك مرحله دعم المرافق
الصحيه بما يضمن عودتها الى عملها الكامل
ثم كذلك يتبعها الى
دعم
المدن الشماليه التي فيها احتياج كذلك اخر
والمرحله
لها اثناء وجود
استقراء مدن الرئيسيه سوف تبدا
الحربيه التطوعيه التي سوف تساهم في اجراء
الجراحات والاجراءات الطبيه اللازمه من
قبل الكوادر السعوديه المستقبل اتمنى لكم
التوفيق شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور عبد الله
الربيع المشرف العام على مركز الملك سلمان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات